I look at the world through a lens of
comedy right so my natural reaction is
always no matter when something happens
and I can't even help it it's why is
that funny I love the idea of reframing
a negative situation into a positive one
it's so inspired that other people want
to support and work with that energy
rise and shine it's an special time good
morning believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
to you that I want to see exploded onto
the world so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message always be joyous over
to you will Smith I look at the world
through a lens of comedy right so my
natural reaction is always no matter
when something happens and I can't even
help it it's why is that funny you know
so even at a funeral I can't help but
think why that's funny you know so it's
it's extremely helpful for me just
psychologically that no matter what's
going on I can't keep my mind from
finding jokes you know so it's a it's a
beautiful way to stay joyous and
positive as crazy it might seem to be at
a funeral and think about how is a
situation funny or comical I love the
idea of reframing a negative situation
into a positive one it can really serve
you or reminds me of what Tony Robbins
said of you look at the worst thing
that's ever happened to your life and
ask yourself how can this worst thing
ever be the best thing ever
how do you reframe it to the most
negative situation ever in your life
becomes your biggest strength becomes
your mission helps you follow something
that then have the bigger impact I
really think that for people who get
through a negative situation and makes
them a lot stronger just as a human
being
and quite often the mission that we have
in our lives with things that we want to
contribute and give back is so that
other people don't have to face the same
consequences the same suffering that we
faced so for me I love helping
entrepreneurs I love it it fuels me it
drives me what's the big reason for it
was because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur that I want to make it
easier for other people who are like me
and if you're looking for your mission
just go back to previous pain that you
dealt with and how you've gotten through
it quite often what you want to do is it
is then make it easier for people to not
have to suffer through the same pain and
so the way that Will Smith deals with it
is by comedy is by laughing is by trying
to be joyous that's how he reframe
situations to make it a positive one to
make it more serving to him you could do
that for yourself figure out what you
stand for figure what your one word is
figure out what's at the core of you
figure out what your mission is and then
any negative situation that happens you
can only frame it to one that's
empowering for you the one that serves
you the ones that builds you up and can
inspire others around you as well you
can even practice this right now think
about something that's negative that's
happened in the past week for you maybe
it happened today maybe there's
something that really drove you up the
wall today that got you really negative
really upset really unhappy or something
happened yesterday or the day before
usually we don't they go so far back if
you're looking a year back is something
negative to happen to you you're living
a pretty joyous life but take something
negative to happen recently and just
think how can I reframe this what do I
stand for what's one of my most
important core values and how can I
bring that to the situation so that it
inspires me and empowers me and that
right now as you're doing it as you're
building the muscle you won't do it in
the moment
you'll be negative you'll embrace it you
know you'll feel all the negative
feelings and maybe the next day you'll
be able to be more positive about it
find the way through your goal is to get
that distance tighter so that it's not
the next day it's three hours later and
then it's two hours later and then it's
one hour later and then 20 minutes and
then eventually get to the point where
it's almost instantaneous where you've
trained yourself so much that when a
negative thought comes into your head
when a negative experiences happening
around you that you're reframing it to
serve you to be empowering so that the
next time you're at a funeral you're
laughing your way through it or you're
finding your positive way to really deal
with negative situations now the special
bonus cooked for you but before getting
to that I have a question of the day for
you which is how do you reframe negative
situations or how would you like to
going forward leave it in the comments
below I'm really curious to see what you
have to say thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso and enjoy the bonus
[Music]
as I commit to happiness fully exactly
what I need is coming towards me because
I become a magnet I become an energy
field that is so magnetizing that is so
excited that's so inspired that other
people want to support and work with
that energy and so when we dwell in the
energy of joy and happiness we become a
magnet for that which we desire so my
hope for you all is to start to think
about the things that you want to
succeed in whether it's succeeding in
romantic relationships are succeeding in
your career or succeeding in your health
goals and make a commitment today to
bring more joy to that area of your life
rather than seeing it as a struggle
rather than pushing forward with all
this angst and negativity and neediness
and control just bring joy to it your
successes will come when you commit to
joy when you commit to happiness
so find more joy in that physical
exercise
I've been going to SoulCycle I
absolutely love it it's so joyful for me
and that's helping me raise my butt
because that was one of my goals and
success and and then we have these
moments where we want to really bring
joy into our career well if you're
having a hard time in the office just
find ways to have more fun and as we
start to elevate that presence of joy we
will begin to magnetize the successes in
our life and so take this very seriously
bring this practice into your day-to-day
experiences and make joy and happiness
your number one priority and recognize
how your successes will be brought to
you in a form far greater than you could
ever imagine when your primary focus is
happiness one entry point is bringing
joy back into our everyday lives because
so many of us and I speak as a complete
culprit you know that just like a
certifiable type-a workaholic driven
personality who basically felt my job is
about getting it all done getting it
done in time getting it accomplished and
joy who is time for joining
and now I feel that not at all that is
like when I'm not joyful I look at what
happened I don't mean I don't mean
joyful like there are no challenges
problems etc I mean like when I'm not
like hey this is great I'm blessed I'm
doing something I love I'm grateful and
when I don't have that feeling and not
I'm off I need two cars correct so joy
kind of really checking in and seeing
how am i doing am i if you don't even
have to check in because you know when
you are in the flow in the joy and when
you're not people who have great
ambitions I guess all of us to be you
know design a spaceship or to become a
president or a senator and there's so
much disappointment we you know so few
people can never really achieve what
their dreams are I'm sometimes
suspicious of these great goals that we
have in mind for ourselves because if we
can get tripped up and become
disappointed and cynical and depressed
about it all a few of us can design
spaceships or become presidents or
become Steven Spielberg maybe better to
get outside of ourselves and and
confront the with with joy and pleasure
and the sense of opportunity every
little simple task forgiven rather than
to try to do the big task rather than to
try to shoot a gone with the wind but
but but do a postcard and then grow from
there even though our eye is on the gone
with the wind maybe where it shouldn't
be maybe maybe that should be something
that as a result of a path that leads to
a goal raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that we believe
that people with passion can change
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details